et puis la semaine se termine avec une
certitude à québec comme nous vous
l'annoncions il ya quelques jours il y
aura bel et bien des pots de budget le
20 février la semaine prochaine donc il
selon toute vraisemblance les élections
seront déclenchées quelques jours plus
tard david hunt il est
une autre annonce un autre indice de
l'imminence d'une campagne électorale
mais le plus probant des indicateurs
c'est le dépôt d'un budget jeudi
prochain et voudrait qu'on atteint le
difficile équilibre budgétaire
maintenant c'est impossible impossible
les lignes de front son tracé difficile
de voir comment on pourrait éviter
l'affrontement électorale si madame
marois les mains attachées avec la ftq
qui veut pas comprimer les dépenses pour
le bien de l'ensemble des québécois bas
ça sera son problème mais on voit
également qu'on joue le même film que
2003 je me suis introduit un budget dans
lequel il y avait un trou pour aller à
l'élection même le projet d'anticosti
est présenté comme une manoeuvre
électorale par les libéraux pourtant
favorable à l'exploration pétrolière
investir 115 millions de fonds publics
serait prématuré faut faire rentrer les
toques landi l'état c'est nous c'est des
contribuables pour les faire entrer au
bon moment dans l'est dans l'histoire du
projet à mon avis ça sent encore une
fois la précipitation et les lecteurs de
la caq parle plutôt d'un risque calculé
où j'étais en affaires le 115 millions
avec un potentiel de gagner 45 milliards
je trouve que c'est un bon risque
ces annonces alimentent l'optimisme des
péquistes déjà gonflés à bloc le
ministre de la justice prévoit même des
gains en montérégie et je pense qu'on
est capable de gagner la prairie
montarville et la porte
plusieurs organisateurs de différentes
formations disent être prêts pour un
déclenchement fin février mais du même
souffle certains admettent que la mi
mars donnerait plus de temps pour roder
les machines politiques et surtout
convaincre des candidats potentiels ici
david gêne-t-il radio canada québec
on retrouve sébastien beauvais à québec
sébastien c'était vraiment la dernière
pierre que ce budget dernière étape vers
une campagne électorale ouais on a
l'impression que la machine est en
marche c'est les pièces sont les pièces
du casse-tête qui sont en train de
tomber en place il ya eu des annonces
économiques il ya une annonce pour
anticosti il est maintenant le budget
l'annnonce du budget rappelez-vous
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière françois
gendron le sage du parti québécois qui
devient il faut qu'on présente des
chiffres aux québécois avant d'aller en
élection c'est exactement ce que pauline
marois fera la semaine prochaine avec
son ministre nicolas marceau alors
l'annnonce du dépôt du budget jeudi
prochain force les partis d'opposition à
se commettre à dire quelles sont leurs
attentes quelles sont leurs demandes
pour le budget c'est exactement ce que
françois legault a été aujourd'hui est
la réponse de madame marois et de dire
c'était possible de satisfaire les
demandes des partis d'opposition donc
aujourd'hui en annonçant le budget et en
forçant les partis d'opposition à se
connaître et se donne aussi un prétexte
pour déclencher les élections influence
les partis d'opposition conduit demandes
irréalistes impossibles à satisfaire il
nous place dans une situation on est
bloqué on ne peut pas aller de l'avant
pour une économie du québec et donc on
va déclencher des élections reste la
dernière pièce du casse-tête qui est le
fait de déclencher des élections que
madame marois va à pause devra déposer
un moment donné et ça c'est tributaire
des sondages m'ont dit ce soir que le
sondage du parti québécois sont assez
bons qu'ils sont solides qu'ils ne
garantissent pas nécessairement une
majorité un peu à l'image des sondages
léger crop qu'on a eues ces dernières
semaines mais on espère bâtir sur les
annonces économiques qui ont été faites
pour peut-être se garantir cette
majorité aux prochaines élections ce qui
est important est ce que j'avais dit
sébastien également ses deux sections
budget là ne passerait jamais au vote à
ce moment-là marois se déferait
elle-même et déclencherait les élections
avant même d'avoir un voiture bus c'est
le scénario où le premier ministre prend
sa prérogative de déclencher lui même
des élections avant même d'être renversé
par l'opposition dont il garde
l'initiative du moment où il déclenche
des élections voilà merci bonne fin de
semaine nous abritons bras